a couple of months ago i made a video on
the six reasons why i quit social media
five years ago and i got a lot of
comments from you guys saying that this
resonated with you
but some of you still had fears so today
i wanted to talk specifically to those
of you who have quit social media or who
intend to quit
but you're thinking okay but now what
but make sure you stick to the end
because that's where i'll be talking
about
the biggest fear that i saw mentioned
throughout the comments
so let's just get down to business the
first question is
how will i promote my business or brand
i love this question because i can
actually speak from experience here
a lot of people worry that if they have
a business
where they're starting to develop a
brand they have to have social media in
order to promote it
it's like it's the only way in today's
high-tech market
right maybe not the only way
there have been many companies who have
spent millions of dollars advertising
and promoting their products and in the
end they have still failed
but even bigger than that i've learned
through books like start with why by
simon sinek or acres of diamonds by
russell conwell
that people are much more likely to buy
an item or a service from you
if they have a connection with you or
what your company stands for
simon specifically says that people
don't buy what you buy
they buy why you're selling it as in
it's not only about the actual product
think about it this way and this is a
personal experience for me
you're choosing between two dentists
they both have the same quality work
one of them does the job they're in
they're out nothing special
the second dentist you can tell that
their motto is to treat you like family
because when you go
in there they recognize you by name they
refer to you by name
and that dennis also remembers little
details like
six months ago your dog had a broken leg
and they ask you about it the next time
you go
who are you much more likely to go to if
you choose the second dentist it's not
because of the
service or the product because it's the
same you end up with the same kind of
teeth cleaning
you're choosing the why they do it
because they treat you like family
my husband and i have never used social
media to promote our business and we
have had several millionaire clients
just through word of mouth alone and i
know that we're not the only ones
ginza george has never had social media
to leverage her hospitality business and
it's worked out well for her
dr cal newport has never had social
media in his life and he's a successful
computer scientist
speaker and author i do not disagree
that social media can help
leverage the advertising of your
business but if avoiding social media is
something that you want to do
know that you don't have to have it in
order to promote your business
the first thing that i would recommend
to you if having a business without
social media is something that you want
to do
is know that your reputation is huge
so make sure to have a clearly defined
why for what you're doing what you're
doing
so that your clients or your customers
can know that through your service
but aside from all of that know that
there are other means that you can use
to get the word out such as attending
networking events
or conferences using email lists or
producing
content online such as courses or
youtube videos
and if you yourself have a business but
don't have social media
share your ideas in the comments i
assure you that there are other people
that are asking the same question
the next question is how will i buy or
sell my stuff
i am almost going on six years now
without social media so i was totally
oblivious to the fact that you can sell
on websites like facebook i had no idea
but when i moved i actually sold and
donated a lot of items
through several different things that i
did the first and probably the simplest
word of mouth my job has a flyer where
you can post things that you're selling
and i know that certain newspapers have
this availability as well
but i also posted pictures in the break
room of certain things that i was
selling
when it came to selling to people that i
knew i had to be mindful
of who i thought could benefit from that
particular item for example
i had a traction device that did not
work for me or my husband it
pulled on his hernia and i hated the
feeling of blood going up to my head
so i did have a friend that had back
problems she had mentioned that to me
before so when i talked to her about
this
device she was so happy to have the deal
there are numerous ways that you can
sell your items
you can do yard sales you can do
consignment sales as well which is
something that i've done
before like clothing if you intend to
donate it or get rid of it anyway
go to consignment shops and they will
actually buy your clothes that are
gently used
or you can use apps like let go which is
something that i personally used
i mean you don't need facebook for this
the next question is
how will i stay in touch with people i
actually talk about this a little bit in
my video on why i quit social media so
i'm not going to go too much into detail
to drag this video on
but the main point that i want to make
is to focus on making connections with
the people in your life
for example if your friend nancy tells
you that she has a job interview in two
weeks
schedule it in your calendar to remember
to call her either beforehand to give
her encouragement
or afterwards to see how it went be
intentional and remember to do this
i actually schedule birthdays on my
phone to remember to call people
and especially keep in touch with
friends or family that are going through
rough times
maybe others haven't done this for you
maybe when you had a surgery or you were
sick
everybody forgot all about you okay so
you know how it feels
don't be that person too be the friend
that cares and is there when it matters
most
when you focus on making deeper
connections and improving the
relationships that you value
you won't feel that need to have
hundreds of superficial friendships and
comments and likes
the next question what if i lose my
friends
i'm gonna give you the cold hard truth
be prepared that you will
likely lose some friends but i'll give
you a secret
these are just friends that you thought
you had that's okay
it's a good thing about 10 years ago my
husband had a great job where he was
making lots of money
but he spent it all on hosting parties
with free alcohol
and if his buddies needed cash for some
reason he would give it to them
not ever really expecting it back as you
can imagine he had lots of friends
during this time
but when he was rear-ended lost his job
because he wasn't able to work anymore
ended up in a wheelchair and doctors
told him that he was never going to walk
again
because of his back injury only four
friends ever visited him or called him
up to see how he was doing
and those friends that he had helped out
when they needed money
guess where they were when he had lost
his job and he had thousands to pay in
medical bills
who knows they never showed up so what
do i mean by all of this
is the quantity of friends does not
matter nearly as much as the quality
of your friendships when this happened
to him he didn't really
lose friends because they weren't
friends to begin with the weeds just
remove themselves
you don't need weeds in your life you
want people in your life that actually
care about you
people that motivate you to be better or
people that you'd like to learn
something from or that you'd like to be
more like
people that inspire you to be a better
version of yourself keep in touch with
these people
because the rest they're just weeds the
next question is
how will i meet new people okay first of
all there's more than one way to catch a
rabbit
but if you want to meet new people the
first thing that you have to do
is to actually be open to it i mean when
you go to the grocery store don't just
mindlessly stare at your phone or the
magazines at checkout actually smile and
talk to the person behind you
but also make it a point to attend
events where the people that you would
like to meet would likely be at
if you want to make friends that are
focused on the same business goals as
you you might find them at a conference
or networking event if you want friends
of the same faith you might find them at
events at your church
my brother for example corvette dude who
has a corvette and a maserati
loves to talk about cars so he finds
people that have the same interests and
hobbies
at car shows so ask yourself what kind
of people you want to meet in the first
place
and that will lead you to your answer
but before we continue
i have a question for you what do you
think about online dating
do people really get to know each other
on social media what are your thoughts
let me know in the comments the next
question is
what do i do when i'm bored i actually
find this one kind of funny now because
it reminds me of when i
initially quit and how i thought the
world had just ended because i didn't
know what i was going to do with myself
now
this one comes down to one thing habits
your use of social media is a habit when
you quit cold turkey your brain is
stressed out because
now this ritual this habit that you once
did is now gone and there's a void that
it has to fill
and a lot of times this is the reason
that people cave in and they go back to
the habit they tried to kick in the
first place
so you attack this the same way that you
would any other habit and there's lots
of things that you can do
to adopt positive habits and to remove
negative habits
so i'm just gonna share three quick tips
with you tip number one
make it pleasurable quitting social
media can initially leave you with
withdrawal symptoms
so make yourself happy that it's gone by
rewarding yourself
or distracting yourself with happy
things maybe go back to that hobby that
you once had
take a walk in nature exercise take this
time for self-care
or to spend more time with friends and
family take this extra time to invest in
yourself so that you can become a better
version of yourself
instead of reading about other people's
lives or posting all about your life
make your life better tip number two
make it difficult
make it harder to go back by deleting
the apps and getting rid of the accounts
and cut out the triggers that normally
make you go there in the first place
for example if you normally scroll
through social media when you go to bed
then maybe consider placing your phone
across the room or perhaps even better
in another room
or turning your phone off before you go
to bed if your trigger is normally to
pull your phone out and scroll through
social media anytime you have down time
such as for example waiting at a
doctor's office
consider turning your phone off and
taking a book with you instead
and tip number three make yourself
accountable
consider letting the friends know that
we'll actually support you in this
and maybe challenging someone to do it
along with you
or maybe even make it a little bit
better by making there a negative
consequence
if you do go back for example when i put
sodas several years ago i made a bet
with my sister
i told her that if she saw me take even
just one sip of soda
in six months she would get fifty
dollars
this gave me an even bigger incentive to
not go back to that habit these are only
a few tips but for
greater detail on developing or cutting
out habits i
highly highly recommend the book atomic
habits
this is actually a book that i've read a
few times over the years because it's
one that's
easily applicable to any kind of habit
whether you're trying to adopt new
healthier habits such as
exercising reading or eating healthier
or if you're trying to cut off
negative habits that are harmful for you
this book can be a huge help
i'll leave the link in the description
and last but definitely not least i want
to address the biggest
fear that you guys mentioned in the
comments and that is fomo
i think there's a huge deal of fear of
missing out on social media because it's
designed to keep you addicted
there's just something about the ability
to infinitely scroll in those
darn little notifications that you just
want to tap on
because you have to see what it's all
about
at least for me i definitely experience
withdrawal within the first few weeks
but i think that it does
all come down to habits it had become a
habit of mine to
constantly check on the messages check
on the likes scroll through posts
what if i was missing out on something
and once it was gone it was like i had
nothing else to think about but what i
was missing
guys this is short term that feeling
goes away once you get
used to that old habit being gone but
it's a million times easier if you shift
your focus from what you're missing out
on
to what you're gaining you have all this
extra time now think about all the
things that you can do to make your life
better so don't focus on what you're
missing out on focus on
adding more activities that will help
you improve your life get back to those
hobbies you love or adopt new hobbies
love the people in your life and live
fully when you're living a life you love
you will not have time to miss those
apps this list of questions is by no
means exhaustive and i probably missed
several points so if you guys have other
suggestions or ideas
please share them in the comments
because there are other people asking
what do i do that is it for today guys
if you like this video please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe so that you
won't miss out on my videos
i thank you so much for watching and i
can't wait to see you in the next one